The room that you see behind me is called the Surge Room...
...and that's where we literally surge personnel in a crisis.
We keep the phones and the computers always on,...
...so that we can provide instant access and start fusing information...
...to provide a summary for the decision makers in the White House,...
...so that they can make the decisions in response to that situation or crisis.
And hence the clever name, Situation Room.
1/3 of the personnel come from the Intelligence Community,...
...1/3 come from the Department of Homeland Security...
...and the remainder comes from the US Military.
We are sent here because we're apolitical.
We're not Democrats. We're not Republicans.
We're here to support our nation,...
...and the President of the United States, and the institution of the presidency.
And all of the people who work in the White House Situation Room...
...are simply the best and the brightest that this nation can offer.
And they do the very best job that they can do.
Wolf Blitzer sits about a mile away, I think in his Situation Room...
...but not the White House Situation Room.